[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اهلا بكم في حصاد
الليله معكم محمد كريشان وفي العناوين
مع استمرار الجهود المكثفه لانتشال جثث
ضحايا سيول درنه منظمه الصحه العالميه
تؤكد ان اكثر من ثمانيه الاف شخص ما زالوا
مفقودين والحكومه المكلفه من البرلمان
تدعو الى مؤتمر دولي لاعاده اعمار المناطق
المتضرره
السلطات المغربيه تمهد لبدء اعاده الاعمار
باحصاء للمباني المتضرره من الزلزال وتقول
ان ثلثي سكان المناطق المنكوبه تضرروا
وتقدر عددهم بنحو ثلاثه ملايين
وتدابير استثنائيه لمساعده الاف الطلاب في
تلك المناطق على مواكبه العام الدراسي
مقتل احد جنودها في قصف صاروخي اوكراني
اصاب مقر اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي في
القرن والبيت الابيض يمتنع عن تاكيد
تقارير عن التوجه لتزويد كييف بصواريخ
بعيده المدى لاول مره ويقول ان الدعم
الامريكي لاوكرانيا مستمر
ارمن كارباخ يبداون تسليم سلاحي تحت اشراف
قوات حفظ السلام الروسيه وممثلوهم يواصلون
المحادثات مع اذربيجان بشان الضمانات
الامنيه ووضعهم
احتجاجات متصاعده في ريفان على تعامل رئيس
الوزراء الارميني مع الازمه
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله مساءكم مع مروري اثني عشر يوما
على السيوله التي ضربت درن ليبيه لا يزال
حجم الكارثه عصيا على التقدير فقد اعلن
جهاز الاسعاف والطوارئ انتشارا 226 جثه من
ميناء درنه ونقلها الى مقبره مرطوبه شرقيه
المدينه وذلك بعد اخذ العينات وانتهاء
عمليه التعرف على ذويها هذا وتواصل طواقم
الانقاذ جهودها للعثور على جثث المفقودين
تحت الانقاد وفي البحر وبعد ان جرفت
السيول عددا من احياء مدينه درنه
وقد قال ستيفاندو جريخ المتحدث باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده ان منظمه
الصحه العالميه احسن اكثر من اربعه الاف
وفاه في درنه بينما لا يزال اكثر من
ثمانيه الاف شخص في عداد المفقودين مشيرا
الى ان الارقام مرشحه لمزيد من الارتفاع
في الايام المقبله
تقول منظمه الصحه العالميه ان اكثر من
4000 حاله وفاه سجلت بدرنه وما زال اكثر
من ثمانيه الاف اخرين في عداد المفقودين
وللاسف من المتوقع ان ترتفع هذه الارقام
كما تاثر اكثر من 43 الف شخص بالامطار
وانهيار السد بحسب المنظمه الدوليه للهجره
اليونيسف شحنت 65 الف طن من الامدادات
الطبيه ومستلزمات حمايه الاطفال
وفي نشره سابقه قناه الناطقه باسم الهلال
الاحمر الليبي في مصراته للجزيره ان عمليه
انتشال الجثث من البحر مستمره رغم الظروف
المناخيه
ليله البارحه تم انتشار 96 جثه جلها من
الاطفال كانت بدات تطفو نتيجه نفس الطريقه
هو انخفاض سرعه الرياح فبدات تطفو فوق سطح
البحر
واوضحت الناطقه باسم الهلال الاحمر الليبي
في مصراته ان التحدي الاكبر امام فرق
الانقاذ المحليه هو ضاله الامكانيات
اللوجستيه في عمليات الاغاثه
الامكانيات بالنسبه لامكانيات الماديه
الامكانيات ضعيفه بالنسبه للفرق لانقاذ
مقارنه بالفرق الاجنبيه الموجوده في عين
المكان
احتياجاتنا تلبوا فيها بطريقه التبرعات
والتطوعات عن طريق فرع الهلال الموجود في
المدينه ولكن
جهودنا لن ترضخ لهذه العوائق ان شاء الله
نقدم ما يمكن تقديمه احسن باذن الله
في الاثناء اعلن رئيس الحكومه الليبيه
المكلف من البرلمان اسامه سعد حماد عقد
مؤتمر دولي لاعاده اعمار ضمنه والمناطق
المتضرره جراء الاعصار والسيول ودعا حماد
المجتمع الدولي للمشاركه في المؤتمر
المقرر عقده في العاشر من اكتوبر تشرين
الاول المقبل في مدينه درنه وقال حماد ان
الدعوه للمؤتمر تاتي نزولا عند رغبه
السكان مدينه درن المنكوبه والمدن
والمناطق المتضرره
لا يتوقف البحر في درنه عن قذف جثث
الضحايا الى شواطئ المدينه في الوقت ذاته
بدا الحديث في ليبيا عما بعد الكارثه
واعاده اعمار ما دمره الاعصار دانييل في
مدن شرقي البلاد ما هو مؤكد ان الاعصار
اتى على ربع مساحه درنه وجرفه بالكامل نحو
البحر اما ما دون ذلك فيبقى ارقاما
واحصاءات تقريبيه غير نهائيه من اجل اعاده
الحياه اليها واعمارها تحتاج المدن
المنكوبه الى نحو سبعه مليارات دولار
فالاعصار دمر نحو 2200 مبنى اما كليا او
جزئيا في مدن شرقي ليبيا وفقا لتقرير
للامم المتحده اذ قدرت الرقعه التي غمرتها
المياه بسته كيلو مترات مربعه في درنه
وحدها بلغ مجمل المباني المتضرره نحو 1500
من بينها
891 مبنى تدمرت بالكامل شردت السيول
الف شخص من درنه ونحو ثلاثه الاف نازح في
البيضاء ونحو 2300 نازح من بنغازي ربع
مليون ليبي في المناطق المنكوبه وفقا
للامم المتحده باتوا الان بامس الحاجه الى
المساعدات الانسانيه وعلى صعيد البنيه
التحتيه فقد اتى الاعصار على شبكه الطرق
والجسور في درنه التي انهارت بشكل كامل
وتتطلب اعاده اعمارها 67 مليون دولار وفقا
للصليب الاحمر فان 284 منشاه تعليميه
تضررت جراء السيول كما تحولت عشرات
المدارس الى ملاجئ للنازحين اما القطاع
الصحي المنهك اصلا فقد اصيب في مقتل بخروج
128 منشاه صحيه من الخدمه
بعد من طرابلس فرج العماري المستشار
السابق للحكومه الليبيه للشؤون الفنيه
والاعمار اهلا وسهلا بك سيد العماري هل
يوجد اجماع ليبي على هذا المؤتمر لاعاده
الاعمار في العاشر من الشهر المقبل
في البدايه مرحبا بك محمد
وبالاخوه المشاهدين
اولا احنا بعدنا نتكلم على ما يخص
مؤتمر اعاده الاعمار نعم هو هناك اجماع
كامل لان الامر جلل والمدينه تحتاج الى
وقفه جاده من كل الاطراف وبالتالي نحن
محتاجين الى ان يتاسس هذا المؤتمر وتكون
فيه مشاركات دوليه لاكتساب الخبره
والمسانده الحقيقيه من الخبرات الدوليه
والمحليه في اعاده اعمار درنه هل المطلوب
هي هذه الخبرات الدوليه تحديدا لان يفترض
ان الاموال متوفره في ليبيا مبدئيا
هو نحن لازم نحن نتكلم عنها المؤتمر ليس
الهدف منا او المقصود منا هو فقط تجميع
الاموال لان حقيقه كما ذكرت حضرتك ان
الاموال متوفره في ليبيا ولكن المهم هو
اداره مرحله ما بعد الكارثه مرحله الاعمار
بما يحقق الاهداف المرجوه من هذه
من هذه العمليه اللي هي عمليه اعاده اعمار
مدينه درنه ونحن بعد ما نتكلم في هذا
السياق نحن محتاجين الى الخبره العالميه
المؤسسات العالميه المتخصصه في مثل هذه
المشروعات لانها اللي صار في مدينه درنه
هو حقيقه كارثه كبيره والمشروعات التي
تتطلبها اعاده الاعمار هي مشروعات ضخمه
ومشروعات كبيره وليبيا وللاسف ان خلال
الفتره الماضيه تفتقر لهذه الخبرات
نعتبر ان لاول مره
ان يحدث مثل هذه الحدث ويترتب عليه مثل
هذا الدمار ويحتاج
لمشروعات ضخمه كما تعلمون ان المشروع
الوحيد اللي اقيم في ليبيا والذين اعتبره
نحنا مشروع ضخم هو مشروع النهر الصناعي
ونجاح هذا المشروع اعتمد على الاستعانه
باحدى الشركات الكبرى في اداره هذا
المشروع وهي شركه براون الروت وبالتالي
نحن محتاجين لهذا المؤتمر ليس فقط لتجميع
الاموال وانما
لتحديد المسار الامثل والالية المثلى
بمساعده المجتمع الدولي والمؤسسات
العالميه
المتخصصه في اداره وتنفيذ المشروعات
الكبرى ولهذا نحن
نؤكد على
اقامه هذا المؤتمر هذه اعاده الاعمار
الضخمه كما وصفتها هل هي معقده ايضا لانها
ربما تتطلب تصورا جديدا لكل المدينه بعد
الذي جرى لها
نعم هي معقده ومشاريعها تكون مشاريع ضخمه
ونحن ننظر لهذه
موضوع اعاده الاعمار على شكل مرحلتين
متواليتين او متوازيتين في نفس الوقت
المرحله الاولى وهي مرحله
اداره المدينه او اداره الازمه ما بعد
الكارثه مباشره او بعد ما يتم
ايقاف عمليه الانتشار الجثث
تنظيف المدينه وهذه المرحله هي المرحله
نحن نسموها المرحله الحاليه لاداره
المدينه واداره الكارثه ما بعد حدوثها
وهذه تتطلب ان الاسراع في تاسيس اداره
محليه
بكفاءه وقدرات عاليه تستطيع ان تدير هذه
المرحله وهذه المرحله ستنقسم الى جزئين
اساسيين الجزء الاول هو تهيئه المدينه في
حد ذاتها
لتكون ملائمه
لعيش السكان سواء القائمين فيها حاليا او
المتضررين او النازحين بعد
رجوعهم الى المدينه وهذا يتطلب ان
اعاده كل ما هو مطلوب
لتوفير الحياه
لسكان المدينه سوى على مستوى تنظيف
المدينه بالكامل سواء على مستوى توفير
الخدمات الكهرباء المياه الص
الخدمات التعليم خدمات
الصحه كل هذه الخدمات مطلوبه في هذه
المرحله وبعد ذلك ننتقل الى مرحله اخرى
وهي مرحله اعاده اعمار المدينه وهذه تتطلب
حقيقه نظرا لفقر الدوله الليبيه للخبرات
والمؤسسات التي تقدر تستطيع ان
تقوم بهذه الاعمال وبالتالي نحن محتاجين
الى ان يكون هناك جسم يصدر به قرار من
الجهات التشريعيه مع دعم دولي او مؤسسات
دوليه متخصصه في اداره المشروعات الكبرى
وشكرا او مؤسسه دوليه شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
الان الى تداعيات الزلزال في المغرب حيث
قدر وزير الموازنه المغربيه عدد المتضررين
من زلزال الحوز بنحو مليونين وثمانمائه
الف اي ثلثي سكان المناطق المتضرره وبعد
مرور اسبوعين على الزلزال تتواصل عمليه
احصاء المنازل المتضرره في مدن المناطق
المنكوبه وتقوم اللجان التقنيه المختصه في
اقليم شيشاوه باحصاء المباني في اكثر من
750 بلده يقطنها نحو 50 الف شخص ومن
المتوقع ان تستمر هذه العمليه نحو اسبوعين
بعد استكمال معاينه وجرد خمسين الف منزل
تضررت بفعل الزلزال
في الاثناء قالت وزاره التعليم العاليه
المغربيه انها اعتمدت خطه لمساعده الاف
الطلبه المتضررين من زلزال الحوز تتضمن
تتدابير استثنائيه ودعت الوزاره رؤساء
الجامعات المغربيه في المناطق المنكوبه
الى التزام كل اشكال المرونه المتاحه
لتسجيل الطلاب وتقديم تسهيلات بشان
الوثائق المطلوبه وذلك بسبب فقدان كثير من
الوثائق الرسميه تحت انقاذ المنازل التي
دمرها الزلزال وتضمنت الخطه منح الاسبقيه
في الاستفاده من المنح الجامعيه للطلبه
المنحدرين من المناطق المتضرره بالزلزال
فضلا عن توفير خدمات الايواء والمطاعم لهم
معنى من مراكش مراسل للجزيره المختار
العدلاوي مختار اهلا بك كيف تسير كل هذه
الجهود حاليا
ومحمد الجهود تتم بشكل متناسق اليوم تم
الاعلان كما قال الوزير المنتدبه المكلف
فوزي لقجع بالموازنه قال ان 250 دولارا
وهي التعويض المخصص للاسر المتضرره سيبدا
صرفه انطلاقا من نهايه هذا الشهر هذا
التعويض 250 دولارا سيمتد لمده اثنين عشره
شهرا ليكون الاجمال نحو ثلاثه الاف دولار
وهذا المعطى خبر صار جدا
للمنكوبين المعطى الثاني الذي قاله فوزي
القجاح خلال هذا اليوم في الرباط خلال
الجلسه المشتركه للجنه الماليه في مجلس
النواب ومجلس المستشارين غرفتي البرلمان
هو ان اثنين عشره مليار دولار وهي الكلفه
الاجماليه المتوقعه لبرنامج اعاده التاهيل
واسكان واعماره المناطق المتضرره هذا
المبلغ ستشرف عليه وكاله خاصه سيتم
تاسيسها وهذه الوكاله هي التي ستشرف على
عمليه الاعمار هي التي ستنسق بين القطاعات
المعنيه وهي التي ايضا ستقوم بتحديد
المشاريع السوسيو الثقافيه والسوسيو
اجتماعيه التي تهدف الى اعاله هؤلاء
المتضررين وتوفير مصدر رزق لهم خصوصا وان
المناطق المنكوبه تقريبا
68% من السكان سكان الاقاليم المتضرره
الان هم بالفعل يعانون وضعا صعبا بعضهم
فقد مصدر رزقه وقطاعات اخرى كما هو القطاع
السياحي خصوصا في اقليم الحوز تضرر بفعل
تداعيات الزلزال هذا التمويل 12 مليار
دولار سيكون من طرف موازنه الدوله
الجماعات المحليه وايضا هناك دعوه للمجتمع
الدولي
الحركه الدول الشقيقه للمشاركه في هذا
التمويل لان هذا الرقم 12 مليار دولار
سيمتد على خمس سنوات بمعنى ان كل سنه سيتم
صرف مليارين وثمانمائه مليارين و400 مليون
دولار اي نحو مليارين ونصف كل سنه وهو
مبلغ كبير جدا خصوصا وان الدوله المغربيه
تقول ان اولويتها خلال الفتره القادمه هي
اعاده الاعمار هي اعاده الاسكان الاسره
المتضرره تم احصاء اكثر من 50 الف منزل
متضرر تقريبا ثلاث اكثر من 32% من هذه
المنازل دمرت كليا ونحو 68% من المنازل
دمرت جزئيا تقريبا اكثر من ست سبعين الف
انهيار وقع في هذه المناطق المتضرره فيما
يخص التعليم العالي اطلقت ايضا وزاره
التعليم خطه لمساعده الطلبه المنكوبين من
اجل سرعه الولوج الى الج امعات خصوصا وان
بعضهم فقد الوثائق الرسميه شهاده الازدياد
البطاقه الوطنيه
الدبلومات الجامعيه
والشواهد الاخرى وبالتالي لمواجهه هذا
الواقع دعت الوزاره رؤساء الجامعات الى
التعامل بمرونه مع الطلبه محمد شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وهجوما
لافت على مقر اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي
حيث قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان جنديا
روسيا قتل الجراء هجوم اوكرانيا بصواريخها
مجنحه على مقر الاسطول في
شبه جزيره القرم واضافت الوزاره ان مقر
الاسطول التاريخي تضرر جراء هذا الهجوم
وان انظمه الدفاع الجوي اسقطت خمسه صواريخ
موقع استراتيجي للروس وهدف استراتيجي
للاوكرانيين ليست المره الاولى ويبدو انها
لن تكون الاخيره في هذه الحرب هجوم عنيف
على شبه جزيره القرم جنوبيه اوكرانيا تتهم
موسكو القوات الاوكرانيه بضرب مدينه
سيفاستبول في الجزيره يقتل جندي روسي
وتسقط انظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه خمسه
صواريخ اوكرانيه وفق روايه موسكو تتوقف
الحركه على جسر القرم في الجهه الاخرى من
الجزيره التي تسيطر عليها روسيا منذ 2014
لكن في سباستيمول غربا يتضرر مقر اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي وفق الروايه الرسميه
لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه والهدف من الهجوم
الاوكراني على ما يبدو اسطول البحر الاسود
في الجيش الروسي هو وحده فرعيه ضخمه في
البحريه الروسيه نطاق عملياته تمتد من
البحر الاسود الى البحر الابيض المتوسط
ترسو سفن الاسطول في عده موانئ على البحر
الاسود وبحر ازوف توكل الى الاسطول مهمه
تامين حدود روسيا الجنوبيه ويضم اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي غواصات وسفنا قادره
على العمل في البحار البعيده والقريبه
وطائرات حامله للصواريخ وطائرات مخصصه
لمكافحه الغواصات ومقاتلات بالاضافه الى
وحدات قوه خفر السواحل الاستهداف
الاوكراني الواضح للقرب يعيد الى الاذهان
اهميتها للروس من خلالها يشنون الهجوم على
المناطق الجنوبيه برا ومنها تنطلق الهجمات
الجويه على العمق الاوكراني لذلك يراها
الاوكرانيون هدفا مهما للغايه في المنظور
العسكري خلال حرب وفي المنظور السياسي
بالتاكيد على انها ارض اوكرانيه لا يمكن
التنازل عنها بالتقادم والمنظور السياسي
هذا هو الذي تتحرك فيه كييف بحثا عن دعم
عسكري غربي واشنطن يبحث زيلينسكي مع
الكونجرس ومسؤوليه اداره بايدن السياسيين
او العسكريين دعما يقلب موازين الحرب تلك
حرب لا يبدو ان استهداف القرم المتواصل
سيينهيها لكنه قد يحقق للاوكرانيين ما
يبحثون عنه من اضعاف القدرات العسكريه
الروسيه في الجبهه الجنوبيه بعد اكثر من
600 يوم من القتال
هذا وقد قال البيت الابيض انه لن يؤكد
تقارير بشان تزويد اوكرانيا بانظمه بانظمه
صواريخ التكامس وكان مسؤولون امريكيون
قالوا ان الرئيس جو بايدون ابلغ نظيره
الاوكراني فلودي بان واشنطن ستقدم عددا
محدودا من صواريخ كنز ارض ارض بعيده المدى
للمساعده في الحرب مع روسيا الموصولون
الامريكيون اوضحوا ان هناك نقاشا بشان نوع
وعدد الصواريخ التي سيتم ارسالها الى كياب
ونقلت وسائل اعلام الامريكيه عن مسؤولين
ان واشنطن ستزود الصواريخ المخصصه
لاوكرانيا بقنابل عنقوديه بدلا من راس
حربي واحد وهذا سيمنح اوكرانيا القدره على
استهداف مواقع القياده ومخازن الذخيره خلف
الخطوط الاماميه الروسيه
معنى من اوديسا نتاليا المتحدثه باسم
قياده عمليات الجنوب في الجيش الاوكراني
اهلا وسهلا بك سيدهم نيويورك هذه الصواريخ
الامريكيه اذا مات سلمتها اوكرانيا ما
الذي يمكن ان تغيره في سير المعارك
طيب يجب ان نفهم ان تغيير مسيره الاحداث
والمعارك هذا لن تقم به الصواريخ بل
القوات والجيش الاوكراني نحن نطالب
بصواريخ بعيده المدى لماذا لان الجيش الذي
يحارب ضدنا هو جيش مستعد لحرب طويله المدى
وهم لديهم يد طويله ونحن نحتاج
لقدرات تسمح لنا بضربات بعيده المدى حتى
نقص
ذيل هذا الجيش وهذه الصواريخ اذا ما تمت
الصفقه طبعا ستكون
برؤوس مزوده بقنابل عنقوديه وليس براس
حربي واحد هل هذا تطور مهم بالنسبه لكم
لانها ليس من المهم او الاساسي ان يكون
هناك رؤوس نقديه ام لا بالنسبه لنا الاهم
هو القدره على توجيه ضربات بعيده المدى
حتى لا يكون لدى العدو قدرات ان يقوم
بعمليات من مسافات بعيده وحتى نتمكن وحتى
لا يتمكنوا من امدادات قواتهم بالذخيره
وحتى يعلم وانهم لن يستطيعوا
بالثقه بامنهم وحتى يتراجعوا عن الحدود
الاوكرانيه ذات الاهميه العالميه والمعترف
بها منذ عام 91 ولكن هذه الصواريخ بعيده
المدى السيده هومنيوك ستعني عمليا ان كياب
اصبحت باستمرار تضرب العمق الروسي وهذا
عليه بعض التحفظات لدى الدول الغربيه
سوف ندمر قدرات العدو وذخيرته
بحيث نحرر اراضينا ومناطقنا باسرع وقت
ممكن اوكرانيا ليست مهتمه وليست حريسه على
تدمير روسيا او توجيه ضربات لها وهذا ليس
هدف موضوع امامنا ان روسيا هي من جاءت الى
اراضينا لتدمير اوكرانيا واوكرانيا تريد
ان تدافع عن اراضيها وارادتها وحريتها
واستقلالها بالنسبه لنا من المهم طرد
العدو من مناطقنا واراضنا وان نجدد حدودنا
وسيطر عليها وان لا نسمح لاي احد ولا في
اي وقت من الاوقات التعدي عليها بالنسبه
لاستهداف مقر الاسطول البحر الروسي في
القرن
ما الذي تتوقعونه بعد هذه الضربه
ننتظر انهم سوف يفهمون جيدا اننا نعلم
جيدا اين هم واننا سنستطيع وسوف نستمر في
تدمير كل ما هو موجود بطريقه غير قانونيه
على اراضينا ان الوجود وجود مركز
الاسطول البحري للعدو على اراضينا هذا شيء
غير قانوني ولهذا
حصلوا على ضربتين
ولكن هل تخشون
ردا انتقامي
كبير بعد هذه الضربه
بعد
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير عام 22 ليس
هناك اي انتقام جديد ممكن ان يقوم به
العدو ضد هذه الدوله التي لم تقوم باي عمل
ضدها نحن نفهم جيدا انهم ينتقموا منا حتى
وان لم نقوم باي اعمال هل تفهمون هذا فهم
بداوا بهذه الحرب ضدنا فقط لاننا نعيش
بطريقه التي نعتبرها سليمه
شكرا جزيلا لك نتاليا المتحدثه باسم قياده
عمليات الجنوب في الجيش الاوكراني
الان معنا من موسكو فيكتور الخبير العسكري
والعقيد الاحتياط في الجيش الروسي اهلا
وسهلا بك سيد لتوفيق هذا الحديث الامريكي
الان عن صواريخ ارض ارض بعيده المدى الى
اوكرانيا هل هو خبر سيء لموسكو
كان متوقعا ليس هناك اي جديد في هذه
المساله
نحن اسقطنا مختلف الصواريخ وسوف نسقط هذا
النوع ايضا
حتى اذا ما وصلت هذه الصواريخ لاي نقطه
معينه نفهم ان اوكرانيا تحاول كما يقولون
تحرير اراضيهم ونحن نحاول الدفاع
وتحرير الروس المتواجدين في اوكرانيا
والذين يتعرضوا للاضطهاد والقتل من قبل
النظام الاوكراني ولكن الاهم هنا انهم
يعتقدوا انهم سوف يحرروا اي اراضي تسيطر
عليها روسيا وهذا التخيل بعيد المدى وهم
يعتمدوا على تخيلات يؤمنون بها فليقوموا
بهذا لو ارادوا ولكني اريد ان اقول ان بعد
هذه الضربه ضد مركز الاسطول البحري في
البحر الاسود وتوجيه الضربات بالمسيرات
على القرم هذا
ما سيجبرنا على تحرير لكلايف
واوديس وقطع كل الطرق بين اوكرانيا والبحر
الاسود حتى لا يقوم باي ضربات جديده
بالصواريخ او المسيرات او صواريخ شرم شيدو
ولكن صواريخ بعيده المدى لن تقتصر على
تحرير المناطق مثل ما اشرت ستكون ايضا في
العمق الروسي وهذا
سيعمق المشكله بالنسبه لموسكو
بالطبع هذا قد يزيد الاوضاع صعوبه انهم
يقوموا بتوجيه ضربات بالمسيرات على موسكو
وانجلتين ونعرف ونعرف جيدا هذه الهجمات
وليس هناك شيء جديد في هذا ولكننا سوف نرد
كما سبق لنا الرد ولكن
المبنى مبنى
مركز الاستخبارات العسكريه
ومبنى وزاره الدفاع
ومركز
العمليات المضاده
في كيف هذه المباني كلها سليمه حتى الان
ولكن قد نزولها عن الوجود في القريب
العاجل بالنسبه
لضربه البحر الاسود في
مقر الاسطول البحري الروسي هل تعتقد بانه
سيكون له اثر في جاهزيه جهزيه الاسطول
هناك
هذا لن يؤثر على جاهليه الاسطول البحري
ولكن هناك تفصيل واحد مهم في الواقع هذه
الهجمه تمت بمساعده الاستخبارات الامريكيه
والمسيرات التي كانت تحلق فيه المناطق
الحياديه فوق البحر الاسود وهم من يحددون
الاهداف
وهم من يوجهوا طيران هذه الصواريخ ويقوم
بتعديلها ولذلك هنا سؤال كيف يجب ان نقف
ضد الطيران المسيرات الامريكيه فوق البحر
الاسود واعتقد ان المقاتلات والرادارات
الروسيه قريبا سوف تكون قريبه من هذه
المسيرات الامريكيه التي تحلق فوق البحر
الاسود وسوف نغلق كل الالكترونيات التابعه
لهم وكل النتائج التي سوف تحدث بعد هذا
سوف تكون على عاتق الول ايات المتحده واذا
ما كانت الولايات المتحده لا تريد فقدان
مسيراتها فعليهم ان يتوقفوا عن هذه
الاعمال التي باقل حد هي ارهابيه يقومون
بها على ضد القرن فوق البحر الاسود
الخبير العسكري والعقيد الاحتياط في الجيش
الروسي شكرا جزيلا لك
اصبح سلاح المسيرات المفخخه وسيله اساسيه
في جبهات الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
ويقول الجيش الاوكراني ان هذه المسيرات
تلعب دورا مهما في تغيير مجريات الوضع في
ميادين المعركه واكد الجيش الاوكراني
تكميد القوات الروسيه خسائر كبيره
باستخدام هذا النوع من الطائرات
يوم جديد من ايام حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
هنا على محور زفروجيا جنوب شرقي البلاد
حيث يواصل الجيش الاوكراني هجومه المضاد
يخرج الجنود الاوكرانيون في مهمه استطلاع
ورصد لمواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه
نبحث عن اهداف العدو بين احزمه الغابات
وعن ملاجئهم وتجمع الياتهم العسكريه
مهمه فريق كيلي تحديد احداثيات تمركز
القطاع العسكري الروسيه وهو بحث شاق
بالنسبه للفريق في سهول متراميه الاطراف
صفه
تشعر بالاحباط لان عدونا ايضا لديه قدره
على اخفاء معداته لكن ان لم نجدها في
المره الاولى فسنجدها في المره الثانيه او
الثالثه
في الاثناء يتولى فريق ليشي مهمه تفخيخ
طائرته الانتحاريه
يمكن لهذه القنبله تدمير دبابه معاديه اذا
اصطدمت بالمحرك ويمكنها ضرب المدرعات
ونقلات الجند كما يمكننا بواسطتها استهداف
خنادق العدو يعني هذه الطائره رخيصه جدا
لكن ضررها كبير بالنسبه للمعدات الروسيه
اذا قارنت طائره انتحاريه كهذه بدبابه
فسعرها 500 دولار مقابل مليوني دولار سعر
الدبابه
اصبحت هذه المسيرات سلاح رعب على جبهات
القتال فبمقدورها كما يقول الجيش
الاوكراني ان تبطئ تقدم القوات البريه
الروسيه وتخمد نيران الدبابات والمدفعيه
وتغير سير المعارك على الارض
الطائرات الانتحاريه تستطيع الرد وتغيير
الوضع في ساحه المعركه فالمسيره بامكانها
التحرك اسرع من المدفعيه مثلا ومن ثم
تغيير الوضع في الميدان لذا فان اوكرانيا
تعمل على انشاء وحده عسكريه خاصه فيما
باتا يعرف بسلاح المسيرات حيث تؤهل حاليا
عشره الاف جندي اوكراني لهذه المهمه املا
في احراز تقدم في الهجوم المعاكس الذي
بداته قبل شهور
ليسكرام الجزيره اقليم سباروشيا
[موسيقى]
في اخر تطور لقضيه اقليم كاراباخ بدا قبل
ساعات المسلحون الارمن تسليم اسلحتهم
بحضور قوه حفظ السلام الروسيه وذلك بناء
على نتائج المفاوضات التي بدات يوم امس مع
السلطات الاذربيجانيه وفي العاصمه
الارمنيه ايريفيان تواصلت الاحتجاجات
المناهضه لرئيس الوزراء نيكول بشنيان
والرافضه لطريقه ادارته لاسمه الاقليم
عيون على من يدخل ومن يخرج من اقليم كرابا
وعيون اخرى على مسار مفاوضات صعبه بين
المسلحين وحكومه باكو من اولى ثمارها
البدء بتسليم التشكيلات المسلحه اسلحتها
بحضور قوات حفظ السلام الروسيه حديث عن
وجود مسلحين يرفضون الانخراط في مسار
التهدئه تعهدت اذربيجان في وقت سابق بمنح
عفو على كل من يلقي السلاح
وفيما يتعلق بالعسكريين والمقاتلين
السابقين فاتصور اننا سنمنحهم عفوا كجزء
من وقف اطلاق النار لمن يلقي السلاح
ويتعهد بعدم استخدام القوه ضد القوات
الاذربيجانيه اتفق الطرفان ايضا على وصول
قافله انسانيه عبر ممر لاتشين الطريق الذي
يربط ارمينيا بكراباخ كما اوضح بيان ممثلي
الارمن انهم بحثوا اجراءات دخول وخروج
المواطنين من الاقليم وطلبوا بضمان عوده
المهجرين بسبب العمليات العسكريه الى
بيوتهم قبل ساعات من القاء السلاح وصلت
القوات الاذربيجانيه الى مشارفه
عاصمه الاقليم الذي لا يخفت فيه الصراع
الا لينشوب من جديد
الغضب مستمر في شوارع يريفان عاصمه
ارمينيا لليوم الثالث على التوالي تتواصل
الاحتجاجات المعاديه للرئيس الوزراء نيكول
باشنيان المتهم بتقديم تنازلات لباكو
وبسوء اداره قضيه اقليم كهرباء ليلا
ونهارا يتف المتظاهرون من اجل استقالته
وتتوعد المعارضه باطلاق اجراءات مسائله
بحقه في اجتماع لمجلس الوزراء قال بشنيا
ان بلاده لتسعى الى اجلاء ارمن كرباخ بل
تعمل كل ما بوسعها ليعيش هؤلاء بكرامه
ودون خوف
اما بشان موقفنا فيما يتعلق بالترحيل
المحتمل لمواطنين من كارباخ الى ارمينيا
فان ذلك سيحدث عندما يستحيل عليهم العيش
في منازلهم
قد لتسوء التمور اكثر في كرباخ هذه المره
ولكن ذلك لا يعني ان الصراع انتهى ولن
يعود
انضم الينا الان من باكو مراسل الجزيره
عامر لافي كما ينضم الينا من الحدود
الارمنيه الاذر بجنيه مراسلنا محمود
الزئبق اهلا بكما ابدى
عامر عامر كيف تسير عمليه تسليم الاسلحه
من قبل المقاتلين الارمن في اقليم كنباخ
نعم محمد كما تعلم يعني المسؤول عن تنفيذ
ما تم التوافق عليه لايقاف العمليه التي
اسمتها باكو عمليه مكافحه الارهاب هي قوات
حفظ السلام الروسيه وتعلم ان هناك شروط
ثلاثه طبعا تسليم الاسلحه اخراج الاسلحه
الثقيله
والاشراف من قبل هذه القوات وهذا ما تريد
باكو ان تسرع في تنفيذه في هذه المرحله
باكو محمد لديها هدفان رئيسيين الان الاول
هو تسريع ما تم التوافق عليه وهو الان كما
ترى بدات قوات التي تسمى هنا بالميليشيات
الارمنيه في اقليم كاراباخ بتسليم اسلحتها
لكن كثير من المراقبين يعتقدون بان هذا
الامر نعم هم هناك سعاده ورضا هنا في باكو
عن بدء تسليم هذه الاسلحه لكن كثير كما
قلت من المراقبين يرون ان الموضوع لن يكون
سهلا ولن يكون عمليه تسليم هذه الاسلحه
بالس الاعتبار ان هناك ايضا رافضين لعمليه
التسليم وان كان هناك ضغوطات كبيره عليهم
خصوصا بعد ان فقدوا الكثير من القوه ولم
يعد بمقدور الجيش هذه المنطقه جيش كهربائي
ان يقاوم الجيش الاذربي بعد الانتصار
السريع الذي حققه في هذه العمليه التي لم
تستغرق سوى يوم واحد هذه هي النقطه الاولى
كما ذكرنا لكن هناك نقطه ثانيه ايضا مهمه
جدا وجدا لباكو وهي التسريع في ادماج
المواطنين الارمن في اقليم كارباخ
واقناعهم بان يصبحوا مواطنين اذربيجانيين
لديهم كامل الحقوق وعليهم ايضا كامل
الواجبات تعلم بالامس كان هناك اجتماع مع
ممثلين عن السكان الارمن في كارباخ في
مدينه افلاخ اذربيجانيه مع وفد من الحكومه
انتهى هذا الاجتماع دون تحقيق نتائج كبيره
لكن تم التوافق على بدء اجتماعات اخرى
وتحديد موعد جديد لاجتماع اخر
ومن صباح هذا اليوم بدات باكو في ارسال
رسائل يمكن وصفها بالتطمينيه للجانب
الارمني لكي يسرع في هذه العمليه على سبيل
المثال منذ السابعه صباحا وصلت قافله
مساعدات الى او انطلقت نحو عاصمه الاقليم
قافله مساعدات اذربيجانيه وقالت اذربيجان
بان هذه قافله اولى وسيكون هناك قوافل
كثيره وقالت بانها مستعده لايصال كل ما
تحتاجه
كاراباك كل ما تحتاجه استبانه كر عاصمه
هذه المنطقه ايضا بعد ذلك اداء تواردت
التصريحات الرسميه المطمئنه ايضا وخصوصا
تلك التي جاءت على لسان حكمه حاجياف مساعد
رئيس الجمهوريه الذي قال بانه سيكون هناك
عفو عن المقاتلين الذين حاربوا في هذه
المنطقه اذا ما القوا سلاحهم
واكدوا بانه لم يعودوا لي مقاومه محاربه
الجيش الاذربيجانب كل هذه الاجواء التي
تحدث عنها عامر كيف هي
انعكاساتها على الحدود الارمنيه
الادربيجانيه محمود
مساء الخير محمد حقيقه في اقليم كهرباء
هناك مؤشرات ايجابيه كانت ظاهره من حيث
نقل ثلاثين جريحا في الساعات الاخيره
سيتم نقلهم الى داخل ارمينيا لمعالجتهم
عبر معبر لاتشين ايضا عمليه البدء بعمليه
تسليم الاسلحه بهذه السرعه بعد يوم واحد
من تفاهمات افلاخ بدا هذا التفاوض ما بين
اذربيجان بشكل مباشر وما بين جيش كرباخ
للمره الاولى فعليا وان يحقق هذا التفاهم
او هذا بدا هذه المفاوضات هذه النتيجه
السريعه ايضا دخول بعض المواد الغذائيه
والاغاثيه كلها خطوات تشي بان العمليه
تسير على مسار صحيح عمليه اندماج الارمن
ربما لاحقا وعمليه انهاء هذا الصراع نوعا
ما والذي قبل فيه ارمن كاراباخ نوعا ما
كنوع من الاعتراف بانهم لم يعدوا قادرين
على مواجهه اذربيجان
المنوط بها عقب معاهده انهاء الحرب عام
2020 والذي كان ينص على انها ستكون هي
الضامن لحركه العبور عبر معبر لاتشين لكن
هذا الشيء لم يتم المعبر مغلق منذ ديسمبر
الماضي بالتالي هناك هواجز كبيره حتى من
الضامن الروسي موجوده داخل اقليم كاراباخ
هواجز في معظمها هي هواجس امن لكن كما
ذكرت لك المؤشرات التي ظهرت خلال اليوم
تقول ربما ان الامور تسير على المسار
الصحيح شكرا لك محمود الزئبق من الحدود
الارمنيه لدى المجانيه وعمر لافي من باكو
[موسيقى]
في تطورات الاوضاع في السودان قال مراسلنا
ان الجيش السوداني قصف بالمدفعيه الثقيله
مواقع لقوات الدعم السريع شرقيه مدينه
الخرطوم وكشف وزير الصحه السودانيه المكلف
هيثم محمد ابراهيم ان هناك اكثر من 100
مستشفى خرجت عن الخدمه في ولايتي دارفور
والخرطوم بعد اندلاع الحرب في ابريل نيسان
الماضي جاء ذلك خلال لقاء جمعه مع سفيري
قطر والسعوديه في بورسودان واكد الوزير
السوداني خلال الاجتماع على اهميه دعم
الشركاء من الدول الصديقه لقطاع الصحه في
بلاده وقال ان توفير الاحتياجات المستعجله
لبناء النظام الصحي في السودان يحتاج نحو
90 مليون دولار توفر منها الحكومه
السودانيه نحو 30 مليون
ومن الميدان الى الفضاء الدبلوماسيه تنتقل
المواجهه بين الطرفين فقد انتهت معركه كسب
عقولي وقلوب الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
بعد خطاب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان امامها شارحا
تعرض بلاده لحرب تستهدف وحدتها وكيانها
وكان الفريق محمد حمدان دقلو قد حرس هو
الاخر على مخاطبه الجمعيه العامه ولكن من
مكان مجهول للحديث عن السودان جديد بعد
تحميره الجيش وانصار نظام البشير
المسؤوليه عن الحرب لكن المواجهه بين ممثل
شرعي للبلاد لدى المنظمه الدوليه واخر
تلاحق قواته اتهامات بارتكاب انتهاكات
تشكل في الحقيقه جزءا من ازمه السودان
الذي يقول المسؤولون فيه انه يتعرض
لمؤامره ضالعه فيها بجانب الدعم السريع
قوى الاقليميه تقرير فوزي بشرى
الى الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده ينقل
السودان ماساه حربه التي يتفرج عليها
العالم بوصفها صراعا كلاسيكيا على السلطه
وما هي كذلك بحسب رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني الفريق عبد الفتاح البرحان فهي
حرب بنظله تستهدف نسف كيان الدوله
السودانيه منذ الخامس عشر من ابريل
المنصرم
يواجه الشعب السوداني
حرب مدمره
سنتها عليه قوات الدعم السريع
المتمرده
تحالفت معها
مليشيات قبليه
واخرى اقليميه
ودوليه
واستجلبت مرتزقه مختلف لقاء العالم
لتمارس ابشع الجرائم في حق السودانيين
مارتت هذه المجموعات القتل
والنهب والسرقه
والاغتصاب
والاستيلاء على منازل المواطنين
وممتلكاتهم وتاسيسا على هذا السجل من
الانتهاك طلب البرهان المجتمع الدولي
باعتبار قوات الدعم السريع ومن شايعها من
ميليشيات محليه وعابره للحدود طالب
باعتبارها جماعات ارهابيه محذرا من اتساع
عنفها وخطرها ليشمل الاقليم كله وقد تعهد
البرهان بالعمل على تسليم السلطه للمدنيين
بعد فتره انتقاليه قصيره لم يحدد امدها
وذلك عبر انتخابات حره نزيهه يختار عبرها
السودانيون من يحكمهم قول في مديح
الديمقراطيه لا ضامن له والحرب مثل ما هي
صراع في ساحات المواجهه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع هي كذلك صراع
في تاسيس السرديات والخطابات المانحات
عنفها مصوغا
اخلاقيا ومبررا شرعيا لها
هكذا سيظهر الفريق محمد حمدان دقلو قائد
قوات الدعم السريع من حيث لا يعرف مكانه
احد لمخاطبه الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
اتهم حميدتي قياده الجيش وانصار النظام
القديم باجعل الحرب مبشرا بسودان مختلف
[موسيقى]
الذي تمارسه الدوله ضد قطاعات واسعه من
السودانيين لاسيما في اطراف السودان
الذي نظر اليه بانه يسعى لتاسيس خطاب
سياسي عجل محمل بالمظلوميه انما اثرته
العسكريه لدى النظام القديم لم تكن غير
عمله لضرب حركه الهامش في دارفور واسكات
صوتها حركات المسلحه
17 كده وقد تبلغ بحمايه حماسه التبشير
مبلغا يجعل من خطابه للمجتمع الدولي نسفا
باعتبارها تجلي ينصر قويا وماليا لم يقع
لاسره سودانيه ابدا يقول مناويوه
او عشائريه او جهاديه طيبه امر لا ولا رد
السلطه الى الجماهير في السودان الجماهير
انها الاسم الاخر لماساه الحرب فالقتال في
الخرطوم وفي عدد من مناطق البلاد شرد اكثر
من خمسه ملايين سوداني بعد تدمير الاساس
المادي لحياه الناس فالحرب في حقيقتها كما
تراها الجماهير المشرده في الافاق من
بيوتها هي غاره شاغلها الاكبر الغنائم لا
قضايا الديمقراطيه اما اذا استعصت عمليه
حيازه النفوذ والسلطه فليصر الى تدمير
المدينه اقامه الصوره لا تنتهي هنا بل في
التحذيرات مما هو ات فمنظمه الامم المتحده
للطفوله يونيسيف تقول ان 14 مليون طفل
سوداني بحاجه الى دعم انساني عاجل اما
منظمه الاغذيه والزراعه الفاو فتقدر ان
اكثر من 20 مليون شخص في السودان يعانون
من مستويات عاليه
من انعدام الامن القذائي الحاد ومثل هذه
الارقام المحصيه المهددات امن الانسان
السوداني تجعل من الحرب امرا وجوديا اكثر
من كونه صراعا سياسيا انه صراع على كيان
الدوله
الينا من باريس محمد طورشينا الكاتب
والباحث السياسي السوداني اهلا وسهلا بك
سيد طرشين كيف تتصور ان يكون رد الجمعيه
العامه او المجتمع الدولي كما يوصف بعد ان
استمع
لخطابين ان صح التعبير عن وضع السودان
في البلد استاذ محمد وكذلك الساده
المشاهدين الكرام هو بلال شكه مواقف
المجتمع الدولي مرتبطه ارتباط وثيقه
بعوامل عده اولها المصالح وتاثير المشهد
في السودان على مصالح تلك القوه اذا كانت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه باعتبارها
واكبر داعم للامم المتحده ولا المانيا وما
تبقى من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
السرديه المصالح هي التي تحكم هذه
التوجهات فبالتالي
في تقدير البرهان استطاع انه يوصل العديد
من الرسائل الى المجتمع والدولي لا سيما
على هامش الخطاب اول هامش المشاركه في
المطار العام للامم المتحده حيث التقى عدد
من المسؤولين الامويين الكبار لا سيما
المدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
فضلا عن ذلك مساعده الامين العام للامم
المتحده للشؤون السياسيه وغيرهما هذه
المشاركه في الجمعيه العامه للعمل المتحده
انتصار للحكومه السودانيه ممثله في
البرهان باعتبار ان الكثير من الامور او
طاعات المجتمع الدولي والازمه السودانيه
قبل خروج البرهان من القياده العامه كانت
تختلف تماما عن المغاربه الان باعتبار ان
من قبل كان الحديث بان لا يوجد قائد
للسودان لا توجد رئاسه للسودان وما الى
ذلك فربما الان مشاركته في الامم المتحده
يعني اعتراف ضمنيا بانه هو قائد الدوله
السودانيه في الفتره الانتقاليه او حتى
الخطاب التي الخطاب الذي قدمه البراعه في
تقدير لامس اشواق الكثير من الطامعين بان
تكون الدوله السودانيه
او شمعه مضيئه للمنطقه تسود فيها الانظمه
الشبوليه والمستفيد ده بالرغم انه لم يحدد
للفتره الانتقاليه بالرغم من انه اشار بان
تكون حكومه من الكفاءات الوطنيه وهذه ايضا
جزئيه محل خلاف
اسمح لي فقط سيد ترشد طبعا حضور البرهان
ليس كحضور حميتي
ولكن ربما
المستمعون في نيويورك سيقولون لا يمكن لنا
ان نفعل شيئا طالما هؤلاء لم يتفقوا حتى
على مجرد وقف اطلاق النار وبالتالي
الدعوات لحل في السودان قد تبدو بلا صدى
هو براجب كما ذهبت اليه صحيح باعتبار عنا
الخطاب الذي تناوله البرهان في الجزئيه
المرتبطه بالدعم السريع لم يتحدث بضروره
الانخراط في في او المناظر الاخرى وانما
يتحدث بضروره تصنيف الدعم السريع كجماعه
ارهابيه وحذر من ان العناصر التي
حدود من دول الجوار التي ظلت تشارك الدعم
السريع وسماها بالميليشيات المتحالفه مع
ربما تشكل مهدد امني للسلم والامن الدوليه
في المنطقه بشكل عام فبالتالي هذا يعكس
مقارنه بين الجانب الحكومي لا يرغب في
الوقت الراهن على الاقل في المضي قدما في
قضيه التفاوض اما في الاتجاه الاخر مقروءا
بخطاب محمد حمدان دقله اكدت وابدا استعداد
في ضروره تكون هنالك مباحثات واعاده بناء
وتشكيل مؤسسات الدوله السودانيه وانا في
تقديري محمد حمدان دقله هو ايضا من
الاليات التي ظلت تستخدم من قبل الدوله
السودانيه سواء كان في احد البشير او من
تواجه المجموعات التي ظلت ترفع خطابات
المظلوميه وكذلك التهميش طوال التاريخ
السياسي السوداني فبالتالي الان حاول محمد
حمدان دغله ان يتبنى هذا الخطاب باعتبار
انه هنالك شرائح واسعه وقطاعات واسعه من
الشعب السوداني ظلت تؤمن بان هنالك اختلال
في ميزانات الثروه والسلطه في السودان
وكذلك
العداله فبالتالي تبني هذا الخطاب ربما
يجعل عدد كبير جدا من القوه السياسيه
والمدنيه تحاول ان تكون ظهير سياسي للدعم
السريع شكرا لك محمد طرشين من باريس
فلا الجيش الاسرائيلي انه قصف موقعين
عسكريين لحركه حماس بعد ان اطلقت منهما
بالونات حارقه خلال اليوم واضاف الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان دباباته قصفت موقعا ثالثا
لحماس عند حدود غزه اطلقت منه نيران نيران
تجاه قواته وكانت وزاره الصحه في قطاع غزه
قد قالت ان 26 فلسطينيا اصيبوا برصاص قوات
الاحتلال شرق القطاع خلال التفريق مظاهره
قرب الحدود شرق مدينه غزه واشعل المشاركون
في التظاهره اطارات مطاطيه قرب السياج
الامني تمديدا بالاعتداءات على المسجد
الاقصى وقد اطلقت قوات الاحتلال الرصاصه
والغاز المسيله للدموع باتجاه المتظاهرين
قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو في كلمته امام الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده ان اتفاقيات ابراهام كانت
نقطه تحول في التاريخ وانها حسب قوله فتحت
حقبه جديده من السلام
اتفاقيات وابراهام كانت نقطه تحول في
التاريخ وجميعنا اليوم ننعم بمنافع هذه
الاتفاقيات من استثمار وتجاره كما نتعاون
في مجال الطب والمناخي والزراعه والتصدير
ومجالات اخرى كثيره نحو مليون اسرائيلي
زاروا الامارات في السنوات الثلاث الماضيه
الان بامكان الاسرائيليين ان يطير فوق شبه
الجزيره العربيه للوصول الى الهند
واستراليا والشرق الاقصى من الواضح ان
اتفاقيات ابراهام فتحت حقبه جديده من
السلام وانني اعتقد اننا نقترب اليوم من
تحول اكثر جذريه ومن سم تاريخي بين
اسرائيل والسعوديه هذا السلم سيساهم بشكل
كبير في انهاء النزاع العربي الاسرائيلي
وسيدفع دولا عربيه اخرى لتطبيع علاقاتها
مع اسرائيل وسوف يعزز من احتمالات السلام
مع الفلسطينيين وسيشجعوا مصالحه اوسع بين
اليهوديه والاسلام
[موسيقى]
الديمقراطيه تشاكشومر ان رئيس لجنه
العلاقات الخارجيه في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكيه سين اطار
الديمقراطيز سيتنحى مؤقتا عن منصبه بعد ان
وجهت لجنه محلفين كبرى في ولايه نيويورك
الامريكيهما له ولزوجته بتلقي رشاوه من
ثلاثه رجال اعمال على علاقه بالحكومه
المصريه ووفقا لائحه الاتهام فقد طلب
السيناتور من وزاره الخارجيه معلومات
حساسه تتعلق بالعاملين في السفاره
الامريكيه في القاهره وبناء على اللائحه
فقد تم العمل على ترتيب لقاءات بين
سيناتور من ويندوز ومسؤولين عسكريين
مصريين للاتفاق على انشطه لصالح الحكومه
المصريه ووفق لائحه الاتهام فقد سعى من
هندس على عام 2008 وثمانيه عشر لاقناع
البيت الابيض بالافراج عن 300 مليون دولار
من المساعدات المخصصه لمصر
مستمرون معكم في جوله الحصاد نلتقي بكم
باذن الله على راس السنه
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله مساءكم مستمرون معكم في الحساد
وفي العناوين
مع استمرار الجهود المكثفه لانتشال جثث
ضحايا سيول درنه منظمه الصحه العالميه
تؤكد ان اكثر من ثمانيه الاف شخص ما زالوا
مفقودين والحكومه المكلفه من البرلمان
تدعو الى مؤتمر دولي لاعاده اعمار المناطق
المتضرره
السلطات المغربيه تمهد لبدء اعاده الاعمار
باحصاء للمبالغ المتضرره من الزلزال وتقول
ان ثلثي سكان المناطق المنكوبه تضرروا
وتقدر عددهم بنحو ثلاثه ملايين
وتدابير استثنائيه لمساعده الاف الطلاب في
تلك المناطق على مواكبه العام الدراسي
موسكو تعلن مقتل احد جنودها في قصف صاروخي
اوكراني اصاب مقر اسطول البحر الاسود
الروسي في القرن والبيت الابيض يمتنع عن
تاكيد تقارير عن التوجه لتزويد كييف
بصواريخ
بعيده المدى لاول مره ويقول ان الدعم
الامريكي لاوكرانيا مستمر
ارمن كهربا يبداون تسليم سلاحي تحت اشراف
قوات حفظ السلام الروسيه وممثلوهم يواصلون
المحادثات مع اذربيجان بشان الضمانات
الامنيه ووضعهم
واحتجاجات متصاعده في ريفان على تعامل
رئيس الوزراء الارمني مع الازمه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مع مرور 12 يوما على السيوله
التي ضربت درنا الليبيه لا يزال حجم
الكارثه عصيا على التقدير فقد اعلن جهاز
الاسعاف والطوارئ انتشار 226 جثه من ميناء
درنه ونقلها الى مقبره مرطوبه شرقي
المدينه وذلك بعد اخذ العينات وانتهاء
عمليه التعرف على ذويها هذا وتواصل طواقم
الانقاذ جهودها للعثور على جثث المفقودين
تحت الانقاض وفي البحر بعد ان جرفت السيول
عددا من احياء مدينه درنه
وقد قال ستيفاندو جريك المتحدث باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده ان منظمه
الصحه العالميه احصت اكثر من 4000 وفاه في
درنه بينما لا يزال اكثر من ثمانيه الاف
شخص في عداد المفقودين مشيرا الى ان
الارقام مرشحه لمزيد من الارتفاع في
الايام المقبله
تقول منظمه الصحه العالميه ان اكثر من
4000 حاله وفاه سجلت بدرنه وما زال اكثر
من ثمانيه الاف اخرين في عداد المفقودين
وللاسف من المتوقع ان ترتفع هذه الارقام
كما تاثر اكثر من 43 الف شخص بالامطار
وانهيار السد بحسب المنظمه الدوليه للهجره
اليونيسف شحنت 65 الف طن من الامدادات
الطبيه ومستلزمات حمايه الاطفال
في الاثناء اعلن رئيس الحكومه الليبيه
المكلف من البرلمان اسامه سعد حماد عقد
مؤتمر دوليا لاعاده اعمار مدينه درنه
والمناطق المتضرره جراء الاعصار والسيول
ودعا حماده المجتمع الدولي الى المشاركه
في المؤتمر المقرر عقده في العاشر من
اكتوبر تشرين الاول المقبل في مدينه درنه
وقال حماد ان الدعوه للمؤتمر تاتي نزولا
عند رغبه سكان مدينه درنا المنكوبه والمدن
والمناطق المتضرره
لا يتوقف البحر في درنا عن قذف جثث
الضحايا الى شواطئ المدينه في الوقت ذاته
بدا الحديث في ليبيا عما بعد الكارثه
واعاده اعمار ما دمره الاعصار دانييل في
مدن شرقي البلاد ما هو مؤكد ان الاعصار
اتى على ربع مساحه درنه وجرفه بالكامل نحو
البحر اما ما دون ذلك فيبقى ارقاما
واحصاءات تقريبيه غير نهائيه من اجل اعاده
الحياه اليها واعمارها تحتاج المدن
المنكوبه الى نحو السبعه مليارات دولار
فالاعصار تدمر نحو 2200 مبنى اما كليا او
جزئيا في مدن شرقي ليبيا وفقا لتقرير
للامم المتحده اذ قدرت الرقعه التي غمرتها
المياه بسته كيلو مترات مربعه في درنه
وحدها بلغ مجمل المباني المتضرره نحو 1500
من بينها
891 مبنى تدمرت بالكامل
السيول ثلاثه واربعين الف شخص من درنه
ونحو ثلاثه الاف نازح في البيضاء ونحو
2300 نازح من بنغازي 4 مليون ليبي في
المناطق المنكوبه وفقا للامم المتحده باتل
الان بامس الحاجه الى المساعدات الانسانيه
وعلى صعيد البنيه التحتيه فقد اتى الاعصار
على شبكه الطرق والجسور في درنه التي
انهارت بشكل كامل وتتطلب اعاده اعمارها 67
مليون دولار وفقا للصليب الاحمر فان 284
منشاه تعليميه تضررت جراء السيول كما
تحولت عشرات المدارس الى ملاجئ للنازحين
اما القطاع الصحي المنهك اصلا فقد اصيب في
مقتل بخروج 128 منشاه صحيه من الخدمه
معنا من طرابلس مراسل الجزيره احمد خليفه
اهلا بك احمد كيف يجري الحديث في طرابلس
عن اعاده الاعمار الان في درنه
الحكومه هنا في العاصمه طرابلس محمد وهي
الحكومه الوحده الوطنيه تتحدث عن انها
الان تدرس مرحله ما بعد
رفع الانقاذ وانتشال الجثث تقول ان
المرحله القادمه
تتمثل في وضع مشاريع لمدينه درنه واعمار
مدينه درنه ورصد ميزانيات لذلك وتقول على
سبيل المثال ان وزير الحكم المحلي في
الحكومه بدر الدين التومي سبق وان تحدث مع
الجزيره قائلا انه التقى عدد من السفراء
الغربيين في ليبيا وتشاور معهم في كيفيه
مشاورات اوليه بطبيعه الحال عن كيفيه
اعمار مدينه درنه وان يشارك المجتمع
الدولي في ذلك وبالمناسبه يوم امس زار
العاصمه طرابلس المبعوث الامريكي الخاص
الى
مع قائد قوات القوات الامريكيه في افريقيا
وتدارسا او بحثا مع عبد الحكيم مع عبد
الحميد دبيبه كيفيه اعمار مدينه درنه وتمت
من يقول من الحكومه ان حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه ربما تعتمد على الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في عمليه اعاده الاعمار في درنا
في مقابل ذلك كما تعلم الحكومه الموازيه
في شرق ليبيا تدعو الان الى مؤتمر دولي
لوضع خطه لاعاده اعمار درنه او بحث
امكانيه اعمار درنه من جديد رغم ان ما دمر
او ما دمره السيول والفيضانات في مدينه
درنه هو 25 في المئه فقط من المدينه وليس
كل مدينه درنه ايضا منذ ايام رئيس الحكومه
الموازيه في شرق البلاد الت عددا من ممثلي
شركات الاعمار من مصر
وبحث معهم الخطوات الاوليه لاعاده الاعمار
ايضا المصرف المركزي في العاصمه طرابلس
هنا لم يتحدث في هذا الصدد عن اعمار درنا
لكن الحكومه حكومه الوحده الوطنيه هنا
تتحدث عن ان اجهزتها هناك ماضيه في عملها
فيما يتعلق بتقديم خدمات هذه المواطنين
وازاله اثار السيول والفيضانات وازاله
الركام لتبدا بعدها الخطط التي
تتمثل في اعاده الاعمار من جديد وبناء ما
همه او ما دمرته السيوله التي اجتاحت
المدينه
شكرا لك احمد خليفه من طرابلس
هذا وقد قالت الناطقه باسم الهلال الاحمر
الليبي في مصراته هنا الفائده هنا الفائده
عفوا قالت للجزيره في نشره سابقه ان عمليه
انتشال الجثه من البحر مستمره رغم الظروف
المناخيه
ليله البارحه تم انتشار 96 جثه جلها من
الاطفال كانت بدات تطفو نتيجه نفس الطريقه
هو انخفاض سرعه الرياح فبدات تطفو فوق سطح
البحر
كما اوضحت الناطقه باسم الهلال الاحمر
الليبي في مصراته ان تحدي الاكبر امام فرق
الانقاذ المحليه هو ضاله الامكانات
اللوجستيه في عمليات الاغاثه
الامكانيات بالنسبه لامكانيات الماديه
الامكانيات ضعيفه بالنسبه للفرق لانقاذ
مقاتل بالفرق الاجنبيه الموجوده في عين
المكان
احتياجاتنا تلبوا فيها بطريقه التبرعات
وتطوعات عن طريق فرع الهلال الموجود في
المدينه ولكن
جهودنا لن ترضخ لهذه العوائق ان شاء الله
نقدم ما يمكن تقديمه هو احسن باذن الله
بعد الان من بنغازي محمد سعيد
الليبيه للاغاثه والمساعدات الانسانيه
اهلا بك السيد كيف يسير عملكم الان في
درنه
نعم اولا مساء الخير
ونترحم على الشهداء الذين راحوا ضحيه هذه
الكارثه المناخيه التي اودت بالاف
المواطنين الليبيين وايضا الالاف في عداد
المفقودين نسال الله ان يكونوا من الشهداء
والصديقين وعوده امنه باذن الله للمفقودين
الجهود في مجال الاغاثه والمساعدات
الانسانيه ومستمره حيث سيرت
الحكومه الليبيه الى مدينه دارنا قافله
مساعدات انسانيه بناء على تعليمات السيد
رئيس الحكومه الدكتور اسامه حماد قافله
مساعدات قوامها 26 مركبه من الحجم الكبير
تحتوي على احتياجات الايوائيه والغذائيه
التي تم تزويدها للمخزون الاستراتيجي التي
يوجد في مدينه درنه من اجل رفع المعاناه
عن الاسر في هذا الشان ايضا الجهود مستمره
فيما يتعلق بتوزيع هذه المستلزمات على
الاسر منازلها من خلال الفرق المتطوعين
بالهلال الاحمر والكشاف وايضا الهيئه
العامه للاوقاف والشؤون الاسلاميه في ذات
الوقت الحكومه لا تخفى الباقي المناطق
التي تضرت بالتنسيق المباشر مع وزاره
الحكم المحلي تم
تزويد البلديات التي تضررت المنازل
بمواطنيها باحتياجاتها من احتياجات
الايوائيه
والغذائيه بعد ان تم تقييم الاوضاع
الميدانيه من خلال السلطات المحليه وهي
البلديات المعنيه بهذه الخدمات من خلال
المخزون الاستراتيجي الذي يحدد ان يكون
بمدينه شحات القريبه جدا من مدينه البيضاء
وقريبه بالمناطق التي تضررت شرقيه ليبيا
تحديدا بين مديتي بيضه وايضا مدينه درنه
في اطار رفع المعاناه عن هذه الاسر الجدير
بالذكر ان هناك عشرات الاسر التي تضررت في
هذه المناطق مع
كثره السيول بالاوديه بهذه المناطق والتي
ايضا جرفت الكثير من المنازل الخاصه
بالمواطنين وايضا حاصرت عدد كبير من
المواطنين لعده ايام حتى قامت السلطات
المحليه في هذه المناطق وبتنسيق مع قوات
الجيش في فتح مسارات او طرق بديله لهذه
الطرق حتى يسهل تقديم الخدمات لهم من خلال
فرق الاغاثه وايضا
يعني بعد اذنك
طبعا يوجد اكثر من طرف في عمليات الاغاثه
سواء من شرق البلاد او من او من غربها
وربما هيئات ايضا اجنبيه هل هل تسير
الامور بسلاسه بين كل هذه الاطراف
نعم هذه
المناخيه هي جامعه كل الليبيين في كلمه
سواء من اجل رفع المعاناه على الاسر في
درنا كل المدن الليبيه جاءت وهبت لمساعده
الاهالي في درنه من غرب البلاد من شرقها
من جنوبها تحت رايه واحده وهي رفع
المعاناه حيث التقى الليبيون لمساعده جزء
من هذا الوطن الذي تعرض لهذه الكارثه
المناخيه والهدف هو انساني تقديم يد العون
والمساعده للمتضرين في هذا الشان وايضا
المساعدات الاخرى التي سواء كان قدمتها
الدول المختلفه عربيه واجنبيه او قدمتها
منظمات كمنظمه
الامم المتحده للطفوله الجنسيه وايضا
المفوضيه الساميه لشؤون اللاجئين و برنامج
الغذاء العالمي الذي نقع معه في اتفاقيات
شراكه منذ عام 2011 لتقديم الخدمات اثناء
الحالات الكوارث والاستجابه لهذه الحالات
الانسانيه فالسعي وتقديم الخدمات كان من
مختلف المدن الليبيه دون اقصاء لاي مدينه
من مناطق قد لا يعرف اسمائها بعض الناس
هناك وادي بونجيم وبي وجارف وام الارانب
وممكن مناطق البعض لا يعرفها فهي ساهمت في
دعم اهالي دارنا بالغوث وبالرجال الذين
ساهموا في الدعم والتعاون نعم شكرا لك يا
محمد سعيد الوردي من بلغازي
[موسيقى]
الى تداعيات الزلزال في المغرب حيث قدر
وزير الموازنه المغربيه عدد المتضررين من
زلزال الحوز بنحو مليونين وثمانمائه الف
شخص اي ثلثي سكان المناطق المتضرره وبعد
مرور اصبع اسبوعين على الزلزال تتواصل
عمليه احصاء المنازل المتضرره في مدن
المناطق المنكوبه اذ تقوم اللجان التقنيه
المختصه في اقليم شيشاوه وباحصاء المباني
في اكثر من 700 بلده يقتلها نحو 50 الف
شخص ومن المتوقع ان تستمر هذه العمليه
لنحو اسبوعين بعد استكمال معاينه وجرد
خمسين الف منزل تضررت بفعل الزلزال
[موسيقى]
عضو البرلمان المغربي عن حزب الاستقلال
المشارك في الحكومه اهلا وسهلا بكم كيف
تتابعون في البرلمان هذه الجهود الحكوميه
لحد الان
وفعلا
[موسيقى]
اليوم هناك تضافر جهود كل المتدخلين وفي
مقدمتها
الحكومه بكل قطاعاتها
لتجاوب الفوري مع الحاجيات
والمرتبطه
المنطقه سواء فيما يتعلق الاثار المباشره
للجفاف فيما يتعلق بالايواء واعاده
الايواء او فيما يتعلق بالاثار المتعلقه
بالانعكاسات حول حياه الساكنه سواء على
المستوى الطلابي او على مستوى التلاميدي
من خلال
اعداد
حلول
استثنائيه ومؤقته لحل الاشكاليه مرتبطه
بالتربيه والتعليم اضافه الى ان الاجراءات
التي تحدثت عنها ترتبط بمساعده
المساهمه في تيسير الحياه الطلابيه
بالنسبه للطلبه سواء بالنسبه للانخراط في
الجامعه سواء بالنسبه للمباريات هو فيما
يتعلق
بالسكن الجامعي والاحياء الجامعيه اذا كل
هذه اجراءات موازيه ومواكبه لهذه الكارثه
فيما يتعلق
بالجانب الاساسي اليوم
كما تتبعتم هناك هبه وطنيه فيما يتعلق
بالجانب ديال التضامن ما يتعلق بالجانب
المتعلق بالاواء المرحلي والمؤقات الان
الاجراءات على قدم الوثائق من اجل الاحصاء
النهائي لكل المنازل المتضرره بناء على
التوجيهات الملكيه المرتبطه سواء بالمنازل
المهتمه بشكل كلي اللي هي في حدود 140 الف
درهم او المنازل
التي تضررت بشكل جزئي حدود تمارين الف
درهم اضافه 30,000 درهم لكل المتضررين
اي اي دور للبرلمان في مواكبه هذه
الاجراءات والسعي
والسهر على حسن التطبيقها
ان العمليات اليوم البرلمان من ادوار
الاساسيه هو المراقبه العمل الحكومي لكن
المغاربه
بمؤسساته
كمواطنين في الكوارث والنكبات لا يبقى
الموضوع يرتبط بالمراقبه ولا بالمحاسبه
هناك مجهود تضامني اليوم كانت هناك لجنتي
الماليه منعقده للتعرف عن كتب على
الاجراءات التي
تفضلتم بتقديمها التي قدمها السيد وزير
الميزانيه
والبرلمان يبارك هذه الجهد لانه الجميع
يلاحظ ان هناك جديه وتعاطي واضح ودقيق مع
هذه الكارثه بطريقه مهنيه وبحرفيه كبيره
شيء لذي يجعل ان البرلمان يدعم هذا
العمليه من بين الامور الاساسيه انه
البرلمان بكل مكوناته سواء المجلس النواب
او جسم
في اطار التضامن مع هاد الفئه كان واحد
المساهمه ديال الشهر من الاجره ديال
البرلمانيين والبرلمانيات لكن البرلمانيين
يتابعون اليوم البرلمان ان عطله برلمانيه
ورغم ذلك اللجان تنعقد سواء باحداث الحساب
الخصوصي تم اخبار البرلمان في هذا الاتجاه
سواء بمتابعه الاجراءات التي تقوم بها
الحكومه بشكل مباشر واليوم كان كذلك
الاجتماع ديال لجنتي الماليه للمجلسين
وبالتالي
بالاضافه الى المساهمه ديال البرلمانيين
في عين المكان من خلال المساهمات الطوعيه
والمدنيه شكرا لك عبد القادر
المغربي كنت معنا من الرباط
[موسيقى]
الى تطوراته حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وهجوم
لافت على مقر اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي
حيث قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان جنديا
الروسيا قتل جراء هجوم الاوكراني بصواريخ
مجنحه على مقر الاسطول في سباستوبول بشبه
جزيره القرم واضافه الوزاره ان مقر الاصول
التاريخي تضرر جراء هذا الهجوم وان انظمه
الدفاع الجوي اسقطت خمسه صواريخ
موقع استراتيجي للروس وهدف استراتيجي
للاوكرانيين ليست المره الاولى ويبدو انها
لن تكون الاخيره في هذه الحرب هجوم عنيف
على شبه جزيره القرم جنوبيه اوكرانيا تتهم
موسكو القوات الاوكرانيه بضرب مدينه
سيفاستبول في الجزيره يقتل جندي روسي
وتسقط انظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه خمسه
صواريخ اوكرانيه وفق روايه موسكو تتوقف
الحركه على جسر القرم في الجهه الاخرى من
الجزيره التي تسيطر عليها روسيا منذ 2014
لكن في سباستوبول غربا يتضرر مقر اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي وفق الروايه الرسميه
لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه والهدف من الهجوم
الاوكراني على ما يبدو اسطول البحر الاسود
في الجيش الروسي هو وحده فرعيه ضخمه في
البحريه الروسيه نطاق عملياته تمتد من
البحر الاسود الى البحر الابيض المتوسط
ترسو سفن الاسطول في عده موانئ على البحر
الاسود وبحر ازوف توكل الى الاسطول مهمه
تامين حدود روسيا الجنوبيه ويضم اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي غواصات وسفنا قادره
على العمل في البحار البعيده والقريبه
وطائرات حامله للصواريخ وطائرات مخصصه
لمكافحه الغواصات ومقاتلات بالاضافه الى
وحدات قوه خفر السواحل الاستهداف
الاوكراني الواضح للقرب يعيد الى الاذهان
اهميتها للروس من خلالها يشنون الهجوم على
المناطق الجنوبيه برا ومنها تنطلق الهجمات
الجويه على العمق الاوكراني لذلك يراها
الاوكرانيون هدفا مهما للغايه في المنظور
العسكري خلال حرب وفي المنظور السياسي
بالتاكيد على انها ارض اوكرانيه لا يمكن
التنازل عنها بالتقادم والمنظور السياسي
هذا هو الذي تتحرك فيه كييف بحثا عن دعم
عسك ري غربي واشنطن يبحث زيلينسكي مع
الكونجرس ومسؤوليه اداره بايدن السياسيين
او العسكريين دعما يقلب موازين الحرب تلك
حرب لا يبدو ان استهداف القرم المتواصل
سيينهيها لكنه قد يحقق للاوكرانيين ما
يبحثون عنه من اضعاف القدرات العسكريه
الروسيه في الجبهه الجنوبيه بعد اكثر من
600 يوم من القتال
في الاثناء قال البيت الابيض انه لن يؤكد
التقارير بشان تزويد اوكرانيا بانظمه
الصواريخ وكان مسؤولون امريكيون قالوا ان
الرئيس جو بايدن ابلغ نظيره الاوكراني
ان واشنطن ستقدم عددا محدودا من صواريخ
ارض ارض بعيده المدى للمساعده في الحرب مع
روسيا المسلمون الامريكيون اوضحوا كذلك ان
هناك نقاشا بشان نوعي وعدد الصواريخ التي
سيتم ارسالها الى اوكرانيا ونقلت وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه عن مسؤولين ان واشنطن
ستزود الصواريخ المخصصه لاوكرانيا بقنابل
عنقوديه بدلا من راس حربيا واحد وهذا
سيمنح اوكرانيا القدره على استهداف بواقع
للقياده ومخازن الذخيره خلف الخطوط
الاماميه الروسيه
معنى من بيروت العميد اليسحنى الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا بك السيد
الياس حنا ما اهميه هذه الصواريخ
محمد اولا هي صواريخ بعيده المدى ليست ذات
راس كما ورد في التقرير هي قنابل عنقوديه
تتراوح عدد القنابل الصغيره فيها بين 350
و950
قنبله صغيره وهذا الامر يجب ان نعرف يعني
هل
الاتاكاس الجديد هو لسبعين كيلومتر او لي
300 كم هذا امر مهم جدا ولكن انا اعتقد ان
هذه الاسلحه اذا كانت المدى البعيد هي
ليست مهمه اذا كانت عنقوديه بينما مهمه
اذا استهدفت مراكز اساسيه في العمق الروسي
من هنا تمرير هذا الموضوع
البيت الابيض يبدو يبدو حذرا في تاكيد هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل برايك لماذا
انا اعتقد ان هناك نمط معين من السلوك لدى
البيت الابيض يعني يمرر الخبر وبعدها يتم
تخطي الخطوط الحمر التي وضعتها روسيه من
الى الهايمرز الى الدبابه الى المدفعيه
ومن ثم الى الاف 16 هناك خطوط حمر كثيره
محمد تم تجاوزها ونحن اليوم في هذه
المرحله من المراحل يعني بين الستون شادو
وسكلب الفرنسي واستنشدوا الانجليزي مسافه
250 كم هذا امر مهم جدا خرق الكثير من
الخطوط الحمر فلماذا لا يكون من ضمن هذه
الخطوط في كل مره اعمده اليسحنى يقع
النقاش حول موضوع مره حول الدبابات مره
حول الطائرات اف 16 الان حول هذه الصواريخ
بعيده المدى والكل لاي هدف كل ذلك
دائما هناك منظومه محمد النجاح العسكري
يجب ان يتم القتال فيه من ضمن منظومه يعني
نبدا بالمدفعيه العاديه من عشرين الى 30
كيلومتر الهايمرز الى 80 كم الشادو 250
كيلومتر واليوم اذا تحدثنا عن اتاكمز 300
كيلومتر هذا امر يعطي عمق وبعد اساسي لاي
تقدم عسكري روسي خاصه استهداف على سبيل
المثال شبه جزيره القرم التي هي جزء اساسي
من العمق الروسي اللوجستي ولماذا على سبيل
المثال ايضا ضرب القياده البحريه الاسطول
البحر الاسود لانه البحر الاسود او اسطول
البحر الاسود هو مكلف بنقل اللوجستيه
تحديدا مندا الروسيه للعمق الاوكراني في
الجنوب
اذا اذا كانت بعيده المدى بالمدى الذي
اشرت اليه 300 كيلو متر هل معنى ذلك ان
الحذر او التح فظ الغربي بخصوص استهداف
العمق الروسي الان تقريبا يتلاشى
انا اعتقد هناك خط احمر لدى الرئيس بايدن
من ضمن استراتيجيه كبرى من ضمن الوضوح
الاستراتيجي كما يقال ان لا يتم استهداف
الاراضي الروسيه بزخيره غربيه خاصه اذا
كانت امريكيه من هنا محمد نرى ان كل
المسيرات هي من صنع محلي او من صنع سوفيتي
معدله حتى المسيرات البحريه السطحيه منها
ومنها ما دون تحت المياه التي تستهدف شبه
جديده هي كلها من صنع اوكرانيا حتى صاروخ
النيتون الذي استطاع اغراق البارجه موسكو
هو معدل من قبل اوكرانيا شكرا لك العميد
الياس حنا من بيروت
هذا وقد اصبح سلاح المسيرات المفخخه وسيله
اساسيه في جبهات الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا يقول الجيش الاوكراني ان هذه
المسيرات تلعب دورا مهما في تغيير مجريات
الوضع في ميادين المعرفه واكد الجيش
الاوكراني تكبيد القوات الروسيه خسائر
كبيره باستخدام هذا النوع من الطائرات
يوم جديد من ايام حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
هنا على محور زبروج جنوب شرقي البلاد حيث
يواصل الجيش الاوكراني هجومه المضاد يخرج
الجنود الاوكرانيون في مهمه استطلاع ورصد
لمواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه
نبحث عن اهداف العدو بين احزمه الغابات
وعن ملاجئهم وتجمع الياتهم العسكريه
مهمه فريق كيلي تحديد احداثيات التمركز
القطع العسكري الروسيه وهو بحث شاق
بالنسبه للفريق في سهول متراميه الاطراف
صفه
تشعر بالاحباط لان عدونا ايضا لديه قدره
على اخفاء معداته لكن ان لم نجدها في
المره الاولى فسنجدها في المره الثانيه او
الثالثه
في الاثناء يتولى فريق ليشي مهمه تفخيخ
طائرته الانتحاريه
يمكن لهذه القنبله تدمير دبابه معاديه اذا
اصطدمت بالمحرك ويمكنها ضرب المدرعات
ونقلات الجند كما يمكننا بواسطتها استهداف
خنادق العدو يعني هذه الطائره رخيصه جدا
لكن ضررها كبير بالنسبه للمعدات الروسيه
اذا قارنت طائره انتحاريه كهذه بدبابه
فسعرها 500 دولار مقابل مليوني دولار سعر
الدبابه
اصبحت هذه المسيرات سلاح رعب على جبهات
القتال فبمقدورها كما يقول الجيش
الاوكراني ان تبطئ تقدم القوات البريه
الروسيه وتخمد نيران الدبابات والمدفعيه
وتغير سير المعارك على الارض
الطائرات الانتحاريه تستطيع الرد وتغيير
الوضع في ساحه المعركه فالمسيره بامكانها
التحرك اسرع من المدفعيه مثلا ومن ثم
تغيير الوضع في الميدان لذا فان اوكرانيا
تعمل على انشاء وحده عسكريه خاصه فيما
باتا يعرف بسلاح مسيرات حيث تؤهل حاليا
عشره الاف جندي اوكراني لهذه المهمه املا
في احراز تقدم في الهجوم المعاكس الذي
بداته قبل شهور ليسكر راما الجزيره اقليم
[موسيقى]
في اخر تطور لقضيه اقليم كراباخ بدا قبل
ساعات المسلحون الارمن تسليم اسلحتهم
بحضور قوات حفظ السلام الروسيه وذلك بناء
على نتائج المفاوضات التي بدات يوم امس مع
السلطات الادراجانيا وفي العاصمه الارمنيه
ايريفان تواصلت الاحتجاجات المناهضه لرئيس
الوزراء نيكول بشنيان والرافضه لطريقه
ادارته لازمه الاقليم
عيون على من يدخل ومن يخرج من اقليم
كارابا وعيون اخرى على مسار مفاوضات صعبه
بين المسلحين وحكومه باكو من اولى ثمارها
البدء بتسليم التشكيلات المسلحه اسلحتها
بحضور قوات حفظ السلام الروسيه حديث عن
وجود مسلحين يرفضون الانخراط في مسار
التهدئه تعهدت اذربيجان في وقت سابق بمنح
عفو على كل من يلقي السلاح
وفيما يتعلق بالعسكريين والمقاتلين
السابقين فاتصور اننا سنمنحهم عفوا كجزء
من وقف اطلاق النار لمن يلقي السلاح
ويتعهد بعدم استخدام القوه ضد القوات
الاذربيجانيه اتفق الطرفان ايضا على وصول
قافله انسانيه عبر ممر لاتشين الطريق الذي
يربط ارمينيا بكراباخ كما اوضح بيان ممثلي
الارمن انهم بحثوا اجراءات دخول وخروج
المواطنين من الاقليم وطلبوا بضمان عوده
المهجرين بسبب العمليات العسكريه الى
بيوتهم قبل ساعات من القاء السلاح وصلت
القوات الاذربيجانيه الى مشارفه ستيفانا
كيرت عاصمه الاقليم الذي لا يخفت فيه
الصراع الا لينشب من جديد
قد لا تسوء الامور اكثر في كرباخ هذه
المره ولكن ذلك لا يعني ان الصراع انتهى
ولم يعد
قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الاذر بجانيه
ايخان حاج زاده ان عمليه تسليم الاسلحه من
قبل المجموعات الارمنيه في اقليم كيرابا
مستمره بدعم من قوه حفظ السلام الروسيه
واكد حجز زاده في مقابله مع الجزيره انه
بمجرد انتهاء عمليه نزع السلاح فان باكو
ستكون جاهزه لتقديم ضمانات بشان امنهم
وسلامتهم
فيما يتعلق بالمجموعات المسلحه غير
الشرعيه نحن طالبناهم بالقاء السلاح
وبمجرد ان يفعلوا ذلك وتنتهي عمليه نزع
السلاح بالتاكيد ستكون هناك ضمانات لامنهم
وسلامتهم لكن فيما يتعلق بمجموعه محدده من
المسلحين الذين حاربوا ضد اذربيجان
وارتكبوا جرائم ضد الانسانيه على مدى 30
عاما وهم موجودون على قوائم المطلوبين
بالتاكيد هؤلاء لن يمنحوا اي عفو
قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه قصف موقعين
عسكريين لحركه حماس بعد ان اطلقت منهما
بانونات حارقه واضاف الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
دباباته قصفت موقعا ثالثا لحماس كذلك عند
حدود غزه اطلقت منه نيران تجاه قواته
وكانت وزاره الصحه في قطاع غزه قد قالت ان
26 فلسطينيين اصيبوا برصاص قوات الاحتلال
شرق القطاع خلال تفريق مظاهره قرب الحدود
شرق مدينه غزه واشعل المشاركون في التظاهر
اطارات مطاطيه قرب السياج الامني تمديدا
بالاعتداءات على المسجد الاقصى واطلقت
قوات الاحتلال الرصاصه والغاز المسيله
للدموع باتجاه المتظاهرين
تظاهر محتجون على مقربه من مبنى الامم
المتحده في نيويورك بالتزامن مع القاء
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
كلمته امام الجمعيه العامه حمل المحتجون
اعلاما اسرائيليه ولافتات تندد بحكومه
نتنياهو كما حمل عدد منهم اعلاما فلسطينيه
وهتف المتظاهرون ضد سياسات نتنياهو
معتمرين انه يهدد اسس الديمقراطيه ودعوا
الرئيس الامريكي الى عدم دعمه
وفي كلمتها امام الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بن
يمن نتنياهو ان اتفاقيات ابرهم كانت نقطه
تحول في التاريخ وانها وفق تعبيره فتحت
حقبه جديده من السلام
دي ايه بقى
اتفاقيات وابراهام كانت نقطه تحول في
التاريخ وجميعنا اليوم ننعم بمنافع هذه
الاتفاقيات من استثمار وتجاره كما نتعاون
في مجال الطب والمناخي والزراعه والتصدير
ومجالات اخرى كثيره نحو مليون اسرائيلي
زاروا الامارات في السنوات الثلاث الماضيه
الان بامكان الاسرائيليين ان يطير فوق شبه
الجزيره العربيه للوصول الى الهند
واستراليا والشرق الاقصى من الواضح ان
اتفاقيات ابرهام فتحت حقبه جديده من
السلام وانني اعتقد اننا نقترب اليوم من
تحول اكثر جذريه ومن سم تاريخي بين
اسرائيل والسعوديه هذا السلم سيساهم بشكل
كبير في انهاء النزاع العربي الاسرائيلي
وسيدفع دولا عربيه اخرى لتطبيع علاقاتها
مع اسرائيل وسوف يعزز من احتمالات السلام
مع الفلسطينيين وسيشجعوا مصالحه اوسع بين
اليهوديه والاسلام
[موسيقى]
قالت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كارين
جون بيير ان القضيه الاساسيه بين
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين ستكون جزءا
اساسيا من اي اتفاق تطبيع بين السعوديه
واسرائيل
ليس لدينا اطار رسمي بعد وليس هناك شيء
بين ايدينا جاهز للتوقيع وهناك الكثير من
العمل الذي يتعين علينا القيام به وايه
اتفاقيه تطبيع بين السعوديه واسرائيل
ستتضمن عنصرا جديا للتعامل معه وهو القضيه
الاساسيه بين الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
لكن كما قلت لن نخوض في مزيد من التفاصيل
الان
قال رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني في كلمته امام الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده ان سياسه الخارجيه لبلاده
تعمل على ان يكون العراق جزءا من الحل في
اي مشكله اقليميه او دوليه مع التمسك في
الوقت ذاته برفض اي تدخل في شؤون الداخليه
للعراق وتحت اي ذريعه كانت
لقد حرصنا على بناء سياسه خارجيه مستقله
ومتوازنه تستهدف التعاون
وترتكز على تقريب وجهات النظر والمشتركات
وان يكون العراق مصدر استقرار في محيطه
الاقليمي والدولي
وجزءا من الحل في ايه مشكله اقليميه او
دوليه تؤكد جمهوريه العراق
التزامها بمبادئ القانون الدولي
واحترام جميع القرارات الامميه
وتصميمها على اقامه افضل العلاقات مع
الجميع ولا سيما دول الجوار
ونرفض التدخل بشؤون بلدنا الداخليه وتحت
ايه ذريعه كانت
معنى الان من الامم المتحده مراسلتنا بسان
اهلا بك بيسان ما ابرز محطات الجمعيه
العامه اليوم
ربما الابرز كانت الكلمه الاولى او
الثانيه فعليا وهي كلمه رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتانياهو التي رافقتها
كما سمعنا مظاهرات مناهضه له على خلفيه
التعديلات
القضائيه في كلمه نتنياهو تحدث عن اتفاقات
ابرام للسلام وما جلبت من نافع اقتصاديه
على المنطقه كما قال مشيرا الى ان دائرك
السلام تتسع وان هناك مجال لتحقيق السلام
مع الفلسطينيين كما قال ولكن على
الفلسطينيين كما قال ان ربما يكون جزء من
هذه الاتفاقات الاوسع للسلام طبعا كما
ذكرت كانت تاتي هذه الكلمه بالتزامن مع
مظاهرات مناهضه لنتنياهو ربما في صوره غير
معهوده عاده هنا في الجمعيه العامه حينما
يتحدث رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
وطبعا المتظاهرين كانوا من مجموعات يهوديه
امريكيه
وايضا راينا اعلام فلسطينيه ايضا استمعنا
لرئيس الوزراء العراقي الذي تحدث عن حرص
بلاده على علاقات طيبه مع جيرانها رافضا
التدخل
الاجنبي في شؤون العراق الداخليه
متحدثا عن الفساد وانه تم تحديده كافه وهو
محاربه الفساد من اولويات حكومته داعيا
الدول ايضا الى مساعده العراق في
ملاحقه المتهمين بالفساد واسترداد الاموال
ايضا كان هناك كلمه لرئيس
الجابون الذي ايضا تحدث عن خطوات مقبله
تشهدها عفوا رئيس وزراء الكوبون الذي تحدث
عن خارطه طريق وضعتها الحكومه الانتقاليه
خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين وان النتائج
المرجوه من العمليه السياسيه في الجابون
ستاتي حينما يتم الخوض بعمل سياسيه تتمخد
عن انتخابات شفافه
وطبعا طبعا وضع الدستور واعتماد دستور
جديد لذا كانت هذه ابرز الكلمات يوم غد
محمد ايضا سيشهد كلمات متعدده في اعمال
الجمعيه العامه
لارمينيا واذربيجان ومصر وروسيا ووزير
الخارجيه الروسي
سيتحدث غدا لذا ما زالت اعمال الجمعيه
العامه تستكمل ولكن اليوم ربما نتاني
رحب وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امير
عبداللهيان بالمفاوضات السياسيه بين
السعوديه وجماعه انصار الله الحوثيين وقال
ان طهران تدعم العمليه السياسيه لحل
الازمه في اليمن كما اعرب عبد الحيان خلال
لقائه الى من العام لمنظمه التعاون
الاسلامي ابراهيم طه على هامش اعمال
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده في نيويورك
اعرب عن ارتياح بلاده اساء مسار تطور
العلاقات مع السعوديه والاتفاق على تعزيز
العلاقات بين البلدين
وصف المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر
كنعاني اللقاء الذي جمع وزير الخارجيه
حسين امير عبداللهيان بنظيره المصري سامح
شكري على هامش اعمال الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده في نيويورك وصفه بالتطور الايجابي
في العلاقات الثنائيه مؤكدا انه فتح افاقا
ايجابيه في مسار العلاقات بين ايران ومصر
اللقاء والحوار بين وزير الخارجيه
الايراني ونظيره المصري تطور ايجابي في
العلاقات الثنائيه وفي اطار الاتجاه
الايجابي للعلاقات الاقليميه بين ايران
وجيرانها اللقاء كان جيدا للغايه ونامل ان
نشهد مستقبلا خطوات ايجابيه جديده في مسار
العلاقات بين ايران ومصر بناء على الاراده
الايجابيه للبلدين
الديمقراطيه ان رئيس لجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكيه سنر
الديمقراطي
سيتنحى مؤقتا عن منصبه بعد ان وجهت لجنه
محلفين كبرى في ولايه نيويورك الامريكيه
وجهت له تهما له ولزوجته بتلقي الرشاوه من
ثلاثه رجال اعمال على علاقه بالحكومه
المصريه ووفق لائحه الاتهام فقد طلب
سيناتور من وزاره الخارجيه معلومات حساسه
تتعلق بالعاملين في السفاره الامريكيه في
القاهره وبناء على اللائحه فقد تم العمل
على ترتيب لقاءات بين سنتر مانديناز
ومسؤولين عسكريين مصريين للاتفاق على
انشطه لصالح الحكومه المصريه ووفق لاحد
الاتهام كذلك فقد سعى من انداز من انداز
على عام 2018 لاقناع البيت الابيض
بالافراج عن 300 مليون دولار من المساعدات
المخصصه لمصر
في تطورات الاوضاع في السودان قال مراسل
الجزيره ان الجيش السوداني قصف بالمدفعيه
الثقيله مواقع لقوات الدعم السريع شرقي
مدينه الخرطوم
كما كشف وزير الصحه السودانيه المكلف هيثم
محمد ابراهيم ان هناك اكثر من مئه مستشفى
خرجت عن الخدمه في ولايتي دارفور والخرطوم
بعد اندلاع الحرب في ابريل نيسان الماضي
جاء ذلك خلال لقاء جمعه مع سفيري قطر
والسعوديه في بورتسودان واكد الوزير
السوداني خلال الاجتماع على اهميه دعم
الشركاء من الدول الصديقه لقطاع الصحه في
بلاده وقال ان توفير الاحتياجات المستعجله
لبناء النظام الصحي في السودان يحتاج نحو
90 مليون دولار توفر منها الحكومه
السودانيه نحو 30 مليونا
ومن الميدان الى الفضاء الدبلوماسي تنتقل
المواجهه بين الطرفين فقد انتهت معركه كسب
عقولي وقلوب الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
بعد خطاب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان امامها شارحا
تعرض بلاده لحرب تستهدف وحدتها وكيانها
كما قال وكان الفريق محمد حمدانو قد حرص
هو الاخر على مخاطبه الجمعيه العامه ولكن
من مكان مجهول للحديث عن سودان جديد بعد
تحميله الجيش وانصار نظام البشير
المسؤوليه عن الحرب لكن المواجهه بين ممثل
شرعي للبلاد لدى المنظمه الدوليه واخر
تلاحق قواته اتهامات بارتكاب انتهاكات
تشكل جزءا من ازمه السودان الذي يقول
المسؤولون فيه انه يتعرضوا لمؤامره ضالعه
فيها بجانب الدعم السريع هو اقليميه تقرير
فوزي بشرى
الى الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده ينقل
السودان ماساه حربه التي يتفرج عليها
العالم بوصفها صراعا كلاسيكيا على السلطه
وما هي كذلك بحسب رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني الفريق عبد الفتاح البرحان فهي
حرب بنظله تستهدف نسف كيان الدوله
السودانيه منذ الخامس عشر من ابريل
المنصرم
يواجه شعب السوداني
حربا مدمره
سنتها عليه قوات الدعم السريع
المتمرده
تحالفت معها
مليشيات قبليه
واخرى اقليميه
ودوليه
واستجلبت مرتزقه مختلف لقاء العالم
لتمارس ابشع الجرائم في حق السودانيين
مارت هذه المجموعات القتل
والنهب والسرقه
والاغتصاب
والاستيلاء على منازل المواطنين
وممتلكاتهم وتاسيسا على هذا السجل من
الانتهاك طلب البرهان المجتمع الدولي
باعتبار قوات الدعم السريع ومن شايعها من
ميليشيات محليه وعابره للحدود طالب
باعتبارها جماعات ارهابيه محذرا من اتساع
عنفها وخطرها ليشمل الاقليم كله وقد تعهد
البرهان بالعمل على تسليم السلطه للمدنيين
بعد فتره انتقاليه قصيره لم يحدد امدها
وذلك عبر انتخابات حره نزيهه يختار عبرها
السودانيون من يحكمهم قول في مديح
الديمقراطيه لا ضامن له والحرب مثل ما هي
صراع في ساحات المواجهه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع هي كذلك صراع
في تاسيس السرديات والخطابات المانحات
عنفها مصوغا
اخلاقيا ومبررا شرعيا لها
هكذا سيظهر الفريق محمد حمدان دقلو قائد
قوات الدعم السريع من حيث لا يعرف مكانه
احد لمخاطبه الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
اتهم حميدتي قياده الجيش وانصار النظام
القديم باجعل الحرب مبشرا بسودان مختلف
[موسيقى]
الذي تمارسه الدوله ضد القط
اعات من السودانيين لا سيما في
الاطلاق
الذي نظر اليه بانه يسعى لتاسيس خطاب
سياسي عجل محمد بالمظلوميه انما اثرته
العسكريه لدى النظام القديم لم تكن غير
عمله لضرب حركه الهامش في دارفور واسكات
صوتها حركات المسلحه ده ما عندهم يعني مني
تقول عنده عشرين عربيه حاجه زي دي او 17
كده وقد تبلغ بحميه حماسه التبشير مبلغا
يجعل من خطابه للمجتمع الدولي نسفا
باعتبارها تجلي ينصر طويا وماليا لم يقع
لاسره سودانيه ابدا يقول مناويوه
او عشائريه او جهريه طيبه امرا رد
الى الجماهير والسودان الجماهير انها
الاسم الاخر لماساه الحرب فالقتال في
الخرطوم وفي عدد من مناطق البلاد شرد اكثر
من خمسه ملايين سوداني بعد تدمير الاساس
المادي لحياه الناس فالحرب في حقيقتها كما
تراها الجماهير المشرده في الافاق من
بيوتها هي غاره شاغلها الاكبر الغنائم لا
قضايا الديمقراطيه اما اذا استعصت عمليه
حيازه النفوذ والسلطه فليسر الى تدمير
المدينه اقامه الصوره لا تنتهي هنا بل في
التحذيرات مما هو ات فمنظمه الامم المتحده
للطفوله يونيسيف تقول ان 14 مليون طفل
سوداني بحاجه الى دعم انساني عاجل اما
منظمه الاغذيه والزراعه الفاو فتقدر ان
اكثر من 20 مليون شخص في السودان يعانون
من مستويات عاليه من انعدام الامن الغذائي
الحاد ومثل هذه الارقام المحصيه المهددات
امن الانسان السوداني تجعل من الحرب امرا
وجوديا اكثر من كونه صراعا سياسيا انه
صراع على كيان الدوله
والى خبرنا الاخير في جوله الحصائد فقد
اعلنت وزاره الزراعه العراقيه وقفه زراعه
الارز والذره في عموم البلاد حتى اشعار
اخر بسبب شح المياه وقالت الوزاره ان
زراعه الارز هذا العام ستقتصر على مساحات
محدوده من اجل المحافظه على اصناف الارز
العراقيه المعروفه بجودتها يذكر ان زراعه
الارز تحتاج الى كميات كبيره من المياه
دمتم في رعايه الله والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]